this podcast is brought to you by on it
dot com go to on it press in church and
get ten percent off their tremendous
supplements number two
the smarter choice get a great shave at
a great price conveniently delivered
right to your door dollar shave club and
right now dollar shave club is gonna
give you a deal of a lifetime that new
members get the first month of executive
razor with a tube of that dr carver shea
butter for only five dollars with three
free
shipping go to dollarshaveclub.com and
press church
number two let me explain something to
you these days
you can practically get everything on
demand like our podcast listen whatever
you want when it's convenient to you so
why the hell are you still going to the
post office dealing with their limited
hours when you can get stamp postage on
demand with stamps.com
right now right now today use my name
joey for a
four week trial that includes postage
and a digital scale
go to stamps.com right now and press in
joey
welcome to the church of what's
happening now
i love it
monday june 5th [ __ ] uncle joey's
in your living room ralphie mays here
lee syed's here flying jews let me
explain something the weight limit in
this room is definitely over
i'm taking the over i'm taking the over
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
here it is
this is joe perry with the good [ __ ]
heroine
set you free
no one knows a way but may be me oh [ __ ]
here we go
good morning glory here we go
living like a king
in a rock and roll man
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
break up the gorilla biscuits
it's the church of what's happening now
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
happy monday happy tuesday uncle joey
here direct from havana i got my main
man referee may
hi everybody how are you and i call him
rafi may because that's what he said the
invitations out to his wedding
except they put the wrong name out
roughy man my my uh
ex-wife is dyslexic and she proofread it
and i didn't care
yeah good i'm raffy lisa what's going on
everything good in your world
everything's great in my world you got
your little [ __ ] shirt on tonight you're
ready to get shot by your blood it's
your type of knife i don't live anywhere
where bloods are hanging out doesn't
matter i'll hunt you down with your luck
you'll probably go to [ __ ] auntie
chang's dumpling palace
you'll end up with [ __ ] ribs and
chicken lizard anthony waffles over
there on sunset oh
[ __ ] we'll see you with your nice little
[ __ ] uh wallacy with your nice little
crippy shirt
and shoot you right in the iranian beard
what are you gonna do what i'm saying
all you could do is keep plugging along
what's going on ralphie may you're
looking good you're feeling good i'm
feeling good coco i'm doing good i just
got back from denver it was tremendous
that place is on fire it's uh it's great
the weed was too good to smoke and it
was too good not to coco i can't lie to
you did d in colorado come by yeah no
his back wasn't feeling no good okay
yeah d is the best i've been trying i
tried to get him out there and um
and uh i tried to get him a hotel room
and my hotel was sold out um
and then uh i've been trying to get him
to vegas
and i want to get uh tammy uh taken care
of tammy's coming but the problem is
that
i'm not dead you're not dead i know so i
got to give her a call i was going to
call her last weekend and say if she
wants to meet us but meet up with us
maybe here
yeah we're here or maybe uh
there was another place i was thinking
well you'll be there
and i could go that weekend and hang out
well you know i mean i've got a big
residency now i mean they've extended me
cocoa for
another couple of years so they do yeah
the first time they've done that in over
20 years you happy
yeah yeah i got a great house i got a
swimming pool
i mean
hot tub swimming pool right there i walk
out it's it's
high walls nobody can see anything walk
out my shorts okay after before while i
got breakfast cooking jump in the pool
it's 100 degrees feel like a champion go
in uh eat breakfast you know have some
coffee wake up and get motivated instead
of being all bummed out and depressed
and laying up in the bed all day you
know it's like more in nashville
um i'm
right now it's half and half i've got to
sell my house there um
uh but i'm gonna buy some land you know
my house is
doubled in price in like eight years
nashville is booming and uh
and so i'm gonna buy like 10 minutes
outside of town and it's ten minute
drive as opposed to a three minute drive
oh yeah i can do it i can do it man he's
landing teepee you know
dude let me tell you
48 tornado comes you check into the
motorcycle stop stop i'll be 20 feet
underground i'm gonna build me one of
them [ __ ] bunkers okay yeah yeah i'm
going deep man cave with certain oxygen
and [ __ ] shut that [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
sorry everybody's hit me up breaking
going they [ __ ] love you you know
it's uh
you look good i feel good coco you know
i feel good we were talking about
divorce when you walked in yeah what i
had gone through you know we were
talking about
like uh the separation was easy for me
because
you don't know you want to be free till
you're free
right people really don't know they want
to be free till they're free they think
that something's going on
things are not clicking you know
you're feeling kind of sluggish but
maybe it's a situation you're in right
you know so
nobody knows they do a divorce until
they're getting divorced
and you go jesus christ thank god i'm
getting divorced
yeah you're not finally yet no not yet
not yet
i don't know i don't know that's uh
as soon as it gets done it's done that's
another hundred thousand probably
paperwork yeah probably it's that's
that's that's all of the bills i get
dude another 60 000 here 70 000 there 85
over here
i mean there's six lawyers involved in
two states
so i mean it just keeps on adding up but
you know
look
i i married a great girl she's a great
mom to my wonderful children and uh god
bless it that's all you could do that's
all you can do i wanted to find love and
be happy and and uh
and just go about a business you know
i wish i wanted that for my ex-wife
i wish
i could be positive for myself
first of all i don't say what i want for
it because you never put it out there
it's like throwing a jab and leaving
yourself open
i just leave it in god's hands because
you know at the end of the day i'm here
yeah and the best revenge of success you
know
yeah so it took me years to learn that
and to come to terms with that so now
i don't bother nobody though no i don't
bother nobody i really keep it
as light as i can yeah i was telling you
that
you walked in before that at times
listen man
i had a really sh
there's two ways to say it ralph and me
and no way is the truth i can tell you i
had a really shitty childhood
but i could tell you i also had a lot of
fun in my childhood right i couldn't
imagine that my mother would have stayed
alive but then she would also found that
i got left back when i was a dumb [ __ ]
so god knows where the [ __ ] that would
have taken it
but at the same time you know
i i had these people around me that were
that at the time i thought i had
superpowers because whatever pain i was
going through
they made me forgot like
either we went to rudy's or we went to
chan's or we smoked a joint or we did a
lot of criminal stupid [ __ ] you know
yeah
and it seems like i've been away from
that for 30 [ __ ] years
like like this month it's dirty
leave sometimes you sit there and go oh
my god i have to do it late this month
is 35 years
since i graduated high school holy [ __ ]
yeah 35 years
the other day i got high and then was
getting anxiety attacked when i thought
about those dates i had to do the math
on paper
that's how [ __ ] blown away i was i'm
like i have to do the math on paper yeah
because this cannot be 35 [ __ ] years
what you're trying to tell me is that 35
years ago i graduated high school
that's what you're trying to [ __ ]
tell me
you know it's [ __ ] you know it's
[ __ ] up you know you just said you got
left back
look they kicked me out of school i
didn't even get to graduate
so like you didn't graduate on stage
either no no what a [ __ ] punishment
that is i know and and uh and my classes
had reunions and they don't invite me
i'm the only one from clarksville
arkansas that's
i don't know
been on tv
got nine specials netflix stand-up comic
and we're not gonna we're not gonna have
it
it's so crazy wow maybe they you know a
couple years ago in 2010 the the class
2010 wanted me to come and give the the
graduation speech
and the [ __ ] school so i canceled a
week of work all right i get a nice suit
made for me all right i got my car
shined up i'm ready to go back like a
doctor and be nice
and two days before they had one of my
old buddies call me up and go nah an
insurance guy is gonna talk
all right the kids wanted me and they
invited me and i accepted and so it's
like that whole thing cost me like
sixty thousand dollars to be called a
[ __ ] it's just like why
why wouldn't y'all let me be there i
don't know
god bless him maybe somebody at
clarksville arkansas is a fan of this i
got my buddy
dirty sanchez he's a nicki is uh right
there running a barbecue a place with
this peckerwood uh white
hillbilly or pill belly
so how long ago did you get drawn out of
school uh i got out of school graduating
1990
so yeah 27 years 27 [ __ ] each year
i know so how long have you my
girlfriend's 25
how long have you been on school it's
going to be 10 years uh [ __ ] this month
so yeah we i'm having a reunion
uh i think it's thanksgiving week
which is weird i don't keep in touch
with anybody one one guy
where where where are you from lee right
outside of boston oh okay like at north
andover uh uh
sudbury it's near i know where sudbury
is oh yeah yeah yeah there used to be a
chinese food place there that had comedy
oh yeah no uh they had comedy in sudbury
yeah i think they have comedy in
worcester what's that that no worcester
had it but and then there's kyle loons
yeah that's okay that's in uh
on route one yeah it's on route one
that's a dean and then sudbury had a
mexi i mean a chinese place that i did
comedy at one time it was owned by nicks
so i did that
was it lotus blossom because that's like
the only thing place there i think so
holy [ __ ] that's crazy yeah i never been
in your hotel
yeah it's a
i don't i've i've i drove through
because you always talk about that joey
about like seeing where you were and one
of the last times i wanted to go see my
mom i wanted to go alone she she ended
up driving me through the town we like
just drove past my old house and it was
weird it was uh kids i babysat are a
junior's in college and
about to go to college now
and you can't go home it's different
yeah it's terrible
it's just uh 35 [ __ ] years ago
are you a different man than you were
then without a doubt first of all you
were already a man right you were
already doing comments yeah right yeah
in high school you were doing kind of
stand up yeah wow see that's completely
i didn't know dick
at 18 19 i had no [ __ ] idea i know i
told you why right yeah well you won the
technician thing well no no before you
the the part that made me want to be a
comedian and not go to college and and
or give a [ __ ] about high school because
i was going to college in high school at
the same time
was
uh i performed at a shaky's pizza
and for and i won like 50 bucks and the
whole table got a tab okay and they were
drinking pictures of beers okay and
slipping me one all right mostly i was
[ __ ] up on big red cokes okay
and uh and [ __ ] we
all right and i got a [ __ ] uh i was
in my 79 ozil color supreme okay
burgundy on burgundy baby okay and and i
was walking out there and this kind of
ugly chick came over and we started
talking and then made out and she blew
me uh by the [ __ ] dumpster behind
shaky's pizza on highway 71 in
fayetteville arkansas
and i said [ __ ] school
[ __ ] it all i wanna be a comedian
i just did five minutes that i've never
done before all right it made people
laugh i got free pizza i got [ __ ] 50
bucks and an ugly girl sucked my dick
i'm in i'm in i'm all in
but the difference between then and now
is i was a kid then
i was a kid
i was a kid because
you know all my friends were much older
so they always talk to me as a kid
because i was the youngest person doing
stand-up in in houston you know
and and and i was a kid i had no
no peers nobody my age at my level stand
up and uh
and and i was
i was pushed around and protected and
everything until i got so mad i almost
killed some of those old [ __ ] in
houston they don't know how close they
came i had a pistol and i was i was out
of my [ __ ] mind okay i was [ __ ] up
on codeine syrup and i was ready to
[ __ ] kill somebody okay i'm serious
and um
uh
i moved out here after the latino laugh
fest
and joey medina and i met you and
being out here was a chance to remake
myself
in the image i wanted to be
and and it was more it was harder than
what it was in houston to survive you
know everything's more expensive and
that
really
from 98 to when my father passed
was me becoming a man
and the last straw was my father passing
i don't think you're a man until
until
you don't know you're a man until your
father passes away and you're no longer
a son
you know you don't have a dad that's
that's the point where you go this [ __ ]
is way the [ __ ] real
okay and i've got to get my [ __ ]
together
and you know have responsibilities
and that's what that's the whole thing
that's the difference
but yeah i am so when you ask me if was
i the same man as i was then i'd say i
wasn't a man
you know
had i had i [ __ ] commented somebody
yes and i had my dick sucked yes was i
18 yes could i vote yes
was i a dumb [ __ ]
way yes was i naive and stupid to the
ways of the world
yes
yes without a doubt
and it took me a long time of getting
motherfucked to learn that lesson at 19
i had the mind of a child
but the essence of a man i had i had a
you know it's so weird like i had to
write this thing
i read this book and they want you
write like your negative positive stuff
and i wrote it was a thing like how
insecure i always was
but confident at the same time
yeah you know as i remember going into
the city with friends of mine and going
when you walk across the street after
you cop
you have to see your body language
you fit right into new york city
i never understood about that until a
couple of years ago what he was saying
you know
but at 19 you had the mind of a [ __ ]
child but the essence
of a man i already had the [ __ ] like
by 22 i already had the answer where a
lot of people now
you're 22 is a lot different than
today's 22.
i mean i mean enough for nothing it's
like you're 22
with the way you had to come up
losing your mom and your stepdad and and
all the [ __ ] you went through you were
forced
way before
you know the biggest parts about being a
man is realizing you got balls for a
[ __ ] reason you've got to live you
got to survive you've got to [ __ ]
work nothing is free you got to [ __ ]
have it to make it happen
and you had to do that you had to
[ __ ] live and so you lived with the
cop okay you lived with you know your
other friends and you go drink and and
the hash ways you'd go down and get you
a yoo-hoo and a roast beef sandwich with
mayo on white okay and you go and she
throw in a little rice pudding you were
raised by a lot of people dude but you
had your roots you know you had you go
around where you are and you had to
survive and you weren't you weren't
given a choice today's kids they ride
bikes with helmets and uh and kids go to
school they've got a hundred thousand
dollars in in college loans they've got
a liberal arts degree and they're living
at their mama's house
that was not you you had no backup plan
no there was nobody no there's no backup
plan i wanted a plan i wanted to go who
doesn't i wanted to go to school i
wanted to have a car like everybody else
yeah i wanted to have nice clothes but
there was no back up and you know what
how some people i always say this how
some people
join a cult or some people join
scientology yeah some people join bikram
yoga
i took the low i took the low uh what do
you call it low hanging fruit and i
became a criminal because that's what
i was not raised to be but uh
groomed
yeah and i was groomed
i had been shown that as a kid i had
been showing a lot of avenues
and i knew how easy it was yeah i had
been doing it you know
i can't believe that the summer
that i turned 16 i hit the number
i had the number for twenty five hundred
dollars on my birthday guys
that's strong did you ever know that
ralphie i don't think i did
it was a two foot blizzard in jersey
holy [ __ ] and what i wanted for my 16th
birthday was i started the day of the
karate tournament yeah all right and the
deal was i was going to get first place
in fighting
and first place in the form
and then i was quitting martial arts
i couldn't take it no more it was too
hard for me to go uptown
and play basketball and have a
girlfriend and talk to friends and then
in the middle of all this i got to take
a bus to union city and walk a mile and
do karate till eight o'clock at night
ten o'clock at night with men there was
just the schedule was two-pack
and besides those guys didn't get high
didn't listen to rock music i loved them
i loved hanging out with them on the
weekends
so that sunday i started at a
competition like in [ __ ] newark
they were gonna cancel it but we they
shoveled the roads
and i got to go to the competition i got
disqualified but before i was leaving no
i'm lying to you i came back from the
competition about 1 30
and north bergen kids are like what are
we going to do and i go let's go to the
movies
let's go to jersey city for the movies
let's take the number one bus and go to
jersey city so as i was leaving my
mother was drinking with the bookie and
his wife and his brother
and the cousin and the people across the
street
and my mom looks at me she goes he wants
to give you
a present
he wants you to put five dollars in a
number what number you want i got 219.
and i just left and i didn't even
[ __ ] think about oh my god i went to
the movies i bought sporting goods in
jersey city
right across the street i used to buy
sporting goods in those days they're
probably still there on in journal
square from where the dude who blew up
the world trade center the first time
the blind guy that was his office
shake collection shake whatever his name
was
but i walk in the [ __ ] door me and my
friends got to take off our shoes
and my mother hugs me and goes
congratulations you hit the number
i go come on what did i win she was for
two 2 500 bucks
so i gave him a 500 tip um
nice i gave my mother 500 and i kept
1500
and the deal was i'm supposed to put in
the bank [ __ ] you yeah i took a nickel
out of that [ __ ] and started
buying acid every weekend
up in pittsburgh doubling my money
tripping my mother every week it was
ridiculous
i was living like a [ __ ] prince
as long as i had that acid i always had
200 cash
yeah because it was a 85-hour investment
and i was getting back 300.
so i was making 215 on every 100 jack i
would sell 100 in two days lee
when you're [ __ ] 16 you're making 215
every two days how many so wait how many
hands of acid would you buy a hundred
for eighty five dollars and selling for
three and then but did you ever think
about like what transporting a hundred
hits of acid across state lines would
have not one time
i could look you in the eye and tell you
that not one time i knew i was going to
sell this northberg in the high school
kids
it was a bubble i was completely safe
completely safe i would sell black
beauties
i would sell ups
and i dabbled a little bit of wheat a
friend of mine joe would sell me a
quarter pound for 200
and i'd sell an ounce for a hundred
so you'd make 200 hours right off the
[ __ ] top i usually make 150 and smoke
pot like a savage for a night with my
buddies
show up with a bag bigger than your
[ __ ] headley
jesus christ
oh my god that that hustle has been
taken away in this country yeah for yeah
see that that was a hustle that was a
way of life
guys like ralphie neighborhood guys they
figure out a way how to make a great
living and not bust their hump
so what they would do is
they would [ __ ] get a job that they
worked eight months of the year but in
june they were guaranteed laid off
they would collect unemployment till
october
and the whole summer how do you think
they lived they got 450 a week cash from
unemployment
plus you made a grand a week either
booking
or selling something
remember you could buy a hundred
quaaludes and sell them at the bar in
one night wow
so it was two hundred dollars for a
hundred percent i could lee
all you gotta do
is take a piece of this quail break it
in half and eat it put it in your pocket
you come to my house at 6 30
you come to my house at eight this is
how quick it was lee i swear to my
mother's grave i swear to my daughter
mercy you come to my house at 8 30
i give you 100 gorilla biscuits right
you don't have to wrap them in aluminum
foil nothing
just put them in your pocket i saw it
done
i saw guys
way dumber than you
and i don't mean that that way i know
guys that are completely idiots you're
college educated
you just wouldn't know you have an arts
degree your body language will give it
up but i i know guys like you right oh
my god that would live at home with
their mothers that on friday and
saturday on friday i'd see them at 8 30.
you get 100 quails they go to a bar and
they buy the half a guy like you would
just buy the half a gorilla biscuit put
it in your pocket
and put these on your eyelids start to
close like that and people would know
people would walk over to you and say
lee what are you holding that's like the
open sign you just tell them right off
the bat i got lulu
who wants to go to lulay because
lodi was a place in new jersey
i i had a an aunt marty bell yeah in
lodi texas okay okay that's so funny so
they used to call him ludai
lee within lee with if it was a friday
night and people were doing
blow at four dollars a piece
everybody who would come to you would
give you a twenty
and take five from me you think it would
look better yeah
nobody would come to you and buy one
quail
so five people by f i mean you you
wouldn't even believe it
you'd be back and once people knew you
had gorilla biscuits good ones
on the weekends thursday friday saturday
[ __ ] all you have to do is go to three
neighborhood bars
you could uber in between those bars and
just drop
60 to 70 off at each bar
and go on your way make your profit see
a guy like ralphine go ralphie you want
to make an extra money here i'm going to
give you this for three dollars a piece
sell them for five ralphie's a dog man
and [ __ ] jazz larue and you leave the
last 30 with ralphie and you just made
yourself 400 [ __ ] bucks
maybe even 600 because you sold 300 of
them that seems a little too easy that's
how easy it was that's how easy it is
did the bee get you i'm looking for it i
know it's just around myself there's a
[ __ ] beer it was
it was so crazy when you think about
and am i ashamed of this ralphie may you
know i can't lie to you no
but there was a time i was an under the
credit [ __ ] credit card dude
and i still to this day out of all this
[ __ ] i did there's two things that i sit
back and giggle
and go how the [ __ ]
hula not hula hands
the ground round
in sundays and i look at you as a man
round round and if you don't believe me
you call george kaladinsky right now
and that's my witness
all right i took joyce to the ground
around the way i would walk in you're
hungry
yeah come on let's take a ride
i'd walk into the ground with you get
what you wanted something
you get the soup the chili get moist
how many wings you want six give him 12.
you're like look at joey and awesome
like the tab would come i go thank you
and i go start walking and you go why we
ain't paying for this
and then you're a [ __ ] accomplice do
you know how many times i did that
i think i did it three or four times
with georgia girl
getaway driver oh yeah without even
knowing it no no no no no in those days
there was always a by the way
i would give you what you're looking for
but it ain't gonna come easy to you
you're either gonna give me a ride a
shirt i gotta take a shower at your
house
i gotta do something
with the turd oh my god yeah [ __ ] you
you gotta give me something
nothing cheap in those days i'll give
you 20 quaaludes but listen we're going
to go to the bronx you got to wait
outside this black neighborhood and keep
the guard going
keep the car on go lock the windows
keep it going don't open a window for
anybody
oh i was hoping you don't need no air
right you don't need no way
your [ __ ] business
you have no [ __ ] idea how easy it was
to make a living but i would go
in 90 no in 85 i was the worst i ever
was
the worst i ever was from was cocaine no
no no 185 i was clean
i was spotless i was just smoking weed
like a [ __ ]
and i went on a six-month tear in the
new york city new northern new jersey
area
that till this day they're scratching
their heads
i would dress up in a suit and go into
office building and take purses and cash
registers
it was [ __ ] envelopes and nothing in
it i throw it away god damn it
i would bring but i would go to safeway
and steal vitamins and sell and tampons
and
what's the itch when you're vaginal
what's that stuff you get cardicil
yeah
you steal it in jersey from fort lee and
like walking over the bridge
to spanish harlem where they pay your
top dollar for that [ __ ] i was a walking
they did that
scam it was like it didn't stop right
the number one thing i did was i kept
three credit cards in my wallet
that were expired expired and expired
one was hot
and expired like and i got away with
this
for six months well that's when they
just did the paper three times a week
lee i would eat at a fine restaurant a
tremendous lunch jesus on the arm for
free i always left the cash tip i think
they looked like it was never a piece of
[ __ ] they invented cameras because of
you i think i think like because of
people like lee you gave them your card
and it was under 50 and it was the
lunchtime crowd
your restaurant had to be packed yeah it
had to be packed if you went in there
when you can't look at it too long they
couldn't look at it too long they would
have to take when they had three of them
for lunch you would go to a restaurant
they had three things in those days they
didn't call me if it was all under 50
dollars 28 32
they didn't call they just wanted this
ching ching you signed and they gave you
the card back did you like look at the
names and only get like a male who like
not like not like a black dude he was
olivia for a week no no listen
i became whatever name you gave me
whether it was muhammad ching sao ho
i was a chinese guy for about two months
when i lived in san francisco dog i was
a chinese guy for at least two or three
months
because i used to go to that [ __ ]
japan japan town up in san francisco and
they were the only people that would
take traveller's checks without a credit
card without a license
they were in on the movement look at the
yakuza they didn't even sign for that
credit card dude you can't you have no
idea well that's how it was you gotta
talk to the people like you own the
joint let me get that watch let me try
it on all right let me get this one what
else you got let me get that one too
boom what's your name sam what's
happening sam everything all right i
made your day today you're gonna make a
nice commission you take uh visa credit
card american express diners club what
do you think yeah here i'm holding a
visa yeah you know what i'm saying i'm
holding a visa but i'm throwing
different options at you i got discover
i got amex what do you want
i got a silver i've seen you do that no
dog you gotta walk in there like you own
the [ __ ] place lee oh my god and the
guy would be smiling having a great time
you give him the card he thank you for
coming thank you for coming mr kim thank
you yes
they're not gonna argue with you every
once in a while they asked you for a
license yeah one out of ten times you
gotta ask for a license then you gotta
run out of then you lost a credit card
the credit card was harder than hot
remember in those days it wasn't what it
is now if i stole a credit card in l.a
and i sent it to you overnight mail in
jersey you had two days to go bananas
because it would only break down in
zones so it would break down in the west
coast zone the mountain the the
whatever you did it on friday you had
till two you had till tuesday oh lee
that was a thousand scams remember in
those days i would say you lead give me
a nickel i'm gonna give you back 550. i
can't do that watch me i go by 500 worth
of travelers checks and we get your
[ __ ] 30 cents on the dollar whatever
and then we bang your t-shirts you have
no ideally
you have no [ __ ] idea i can make your
day i can say you leave you need a vco
yeah
give me a hundred bucks because i'd use
the travelers checks
it would cost me nothing
the travelers checks would cost me
nothing okay 30 cents on the dollar
maybe maybe a favor
like in those days the cubans used to
get a ton of travelers checks but they
couldn't use them because they didn't
speak english
so i was the only [ __ ] that i
upload
so they tell me what they want up in
japan town and i'd get it for them to
charge them a vague for doing it for
them let go 50 of them and what were
they going to do they couldn't use them
themselves they couldn't even speak the
[ __ ] language oh my god
[ __ ] craziness this is the [ __ ] that
used me up in how do you come up with
this stuff as like just on the fly this
is you make these biz like it's you're
running a empire you're out there you're
a one-man army on a daily basis you wake
up in the morning you go to a charities
you order breakfast and you put it on a
tab and you tell them you're gonna be
back by five
and let me tell you something you wanna
know about pressure when you put
breakfast on the [ __ ] tab
and you gotta come back by five with ten
dollars so i gotta make time i'm already
minus ten it's nine a.m i gotta put this
[ __ ] day together here i gotta do a
half gram tonight is ladies night at
[ __ ] apollo
i'm gonna come up with a new shirt i
gotta go to [ __ ] walmart in those
days there was a new one
yeah you know i gotta come up with a
yard stick for that somebody's getting
robbed today
what a [ __ ] nightmare you have no
idea lee you have no [ __ ] idea i'm
very happy that whole [ __ ] today i was
talking to larry when we were talking
about something we're talking about
businesses
and he goes what if you just took the
little business and moved it to vegas
and like let me explain something
that talk borrowing from peter to paypal
eventually you have to they're going to
nail you on something they're going to
realize you don't live in vegas or some
[ __ ] and you're going to go away
that was me 35 years ago yeah [ __ ] it
yeah let's do it who gives a [ __ ] with
no repercussion at all it's the
repercussion that [ __ ] kills you
right
yeah i had when i moved in they i didn't
transfer my electric it was just on
i had it for like a year and a half and
they just turned it off one day
i had to go in and pay i think they end
up being like 1400
are you gonna do dollars
you know it's funny how poor matt becker
i quit high school
that
august like that august performance in
the year yeah i was like there's no
sense of me going back oh my goodness
what am i gonna do with my life
like i was at that point i go what am i
gonna do i'm gonna go to school yeah i
go this is a job but union they promote
from within right these guys make money
i knew all about this company because i
had worked
for a lumber yard that was a masbach
century hardware chain
this was the warehouse so i would talk
to the guys that delivered all this [ __ ]
and they were telling me how much they
enjoyed working there and one day i
realized it was down the block from
where i was living and i went from being
a daytime shift guy to a nighttime
loader
so i said what am i gonna go to school
for i'm making 15 an hour
this ain't bad at all i could do this
forever this takes me [ __ ] four hours
at night
and you know what bro i went back like
in november
and i pegged it out i tried to do all
the credits and they came back to me and
they said you're not gonna graduate on
stage
i said then what the [ __ ] am i doing
this for
yeah
and i don't get invited to anything i
know nothing i don't think either listen
guys i'm over it already like i know
right it's like i have to be over
i miss a lot of those people first of
all no no but i talk to a lot of those
guys yeah i don't see i talk to a lot of
those guys especially now lately
the last few years in fact i want to
give a shout out to my buddies having
open heart surgery
[ __ ] wednesday if
i didn't have breyer this weekend
and my wife didn't pick if my wife
didn't pick tuesday tomorrow to fly
i would have [ __ ] uh
flown back to new york at least monday
yeah this guy went to my mom's wake
wow like i go back that deep with it
with steve avillo and his family and
[ __ ] so
i'll be praying for him on wednesday
open a [ __ ] heart
surgery
place in a band
went home one night i got rushed to the
hospital his heart was beating too much
don't do drugs yeah hasn't done a drug
in 20 [ __ ] years then it happened
again he had an episode again so they
said they have to do something to his
valve so wow
but i was all four years with that kid
that's [ __ ] amazing
35 years and guys you're listening to
this podcast like what the [ __ ] is joey
talking about let me tell you what's
talking about
it goes fast [ __ ]
it goes away real fast
real fast i know next year i know
ralphie 20 years right yeah 98 that's
how fast
this [ __ ] knows i know ralphie
from an apartment to getting a dog to
get married
to having a big house to having two kids
to having two houses and a bus and a bus
now back to one house now back to
our house it's [ __ ] reno tahoe and
back to the ghetto
i'm so lucky dude
the guys at caesars are just treating me
super nice now you know i mean it's it's
phenomenal they're class acts you know
and i can't i can't be mad the way i'm
being treated or nothing i can't even
gripe well listen brother
and like i tell people all the time that
you said it when we were talking earlier
about there's no escalator to the top
you know you're getting you're not
getting paid right now
you're getting paid for this [ __ ] you
did
when you went up to visalia and your
[ __ ] keys fell down the elevator oh
my god i remember that okay
you know who does that happen to her uh
lee what does that mean what happened to
me
you go to a [ __ ] gig you do a great
job
you spent the night you wake up the next
morning you go to the [ __ ] elevator
you go oops
your keys go down that one little crack
that crack and i heard they held for
like a minute yeah i heard they held by
the time
you shook the elevator i could see them
i could see them going down as they hit
the light of every elevator so i saw him
and i could see him down at the bottom
and i'm just like ah
i got hit by a kid who's coming in from
the swimming pool
okay and i had the keys in my hand
and i got hit by that little girl and
on my hand and boom they just
right in the middle it took two years
but the hilton there or the marriott
whatever it is they uh they gave me my
keys back
but luckily i had an extra key in the
car so all i had to do was get it open
and it was settling they couldn't get an
elevated guy no i mean there was a
thousand [ __ ] by the ways yeah and
that's why i'd help you know everybody
like young comics like the other dad
bumped a song dude when i was with my
family and on the way out he goes oh you
know what i've seen you at the comedy
store i just got into i've been doing it
a year goes
what is it
what is it can you tell me and i go time
yeah time and mileage
if you do eight and [ __ ] open mics a
night
i guarantee you 20 [ __ ] years from
now you'll [ __ ] [ __ ] get paid
because that effort will not be [ __ ]
gone unnoticed trust me i'm telling you
you'll know too you'll know sometimes
they give you a check you look at it you
go
that's for that [ __ ] time my finger
bang that indian chicken twin falls i
don't know on a triple run yeah triple
run would send you to all these things
it's only fun though
you know what bro triple runs lee if if
i had the time
i'd go do one i would take you on a
two-week triple run i'd hire you as the
chauffeur yeah just so you see yeah you
know what you would tap by the third
night no i love it i would i would love
it you know what's great is i can do
them now i did one basically uh earlier
this uh or last year but i did it
yeah but it was a bus it was great it
was great i guarantee i wouldn't quit i
mean this is but you're in a car and
you're driving 12 hours totally and then
you're driving and then the next day you
got to get up and drive another 12 hours
and then the next day you drive another
12 hours the last day you're driving
and the thursday you and you've
crisscrossed where you're going to be
like you guys then you have to come back
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're in one night
that's crazy and then you're in missoula
and then you're in yakima but yakima and
wenatchee are only like right there in
washington yeah
in montana [ __ ] montana it's [ __ ]
crazy then you gotta go to lewiston and
then you gotta go over to [ __ ] uh
oregon and you're in [ __ ] coos bay
and then the next day you're in spokane
you're like i drove through spokane five
[ __ ] times who's bae i forgot all
about coos bay oregon man how good is
the [ __ ] crab meat there jesus christ
no no no elite as
i started one from houston
that took us into
somewhere in idaho
and then we got up the next morning
because there's some days you drive
eight hours
there's something because you gotta
remember we gotta do a show
so i get off stage at eleven
eleven 30. you got to have a drink they
pay you you got to talk [ __ ] these
people don't see civilization
they don't see anybody
you're the biggest thing that's come
into that town
since [ __ ] the guy who shot the
president came in there
steve prefontaine yeah no no no no no
it is crazy lee and god forbid if you do
radio
like you usually go to some college
station and you do radio in those towns
they'll come out
yeah you really live in california
what's that like so you got to talk to
them lee
so we're getting back to the room at 1 1
30.
we're up at [ __ ] seven five
driving 10 hours to 5 5 30 get to the
hotel take a shower eat do the [ __ ]
show go right back to bed
and [ __ ] do it all over again
hopefully we catch a six-hour drive
but friday you catch like a 10. and then
if you're lucky it's the same place
maybe an hour
but don't bet on it some nights you got
to [ __ ] drive all night yeah yeah
because
you got to beat snow you got to beat the
snow you got to beat the [ __ ] and now
you got to drive back all saturday night
after you've done it
driving how did you do it joey without
without the uh
gps like can you read a map
this was
1995 lee you bought a map you had a
50-state map yeah okay
at that time my vision was a lot better
than what it is now
i tapped out once i moved to la la had a
different thing thompson guy thompson
guy
that confused the [ __ ] out of me i'm no
[ __ ] phi beta kappa here i'm okay
with maps because i was a boy scout for
three or four days
yeah i was a wee blow four
i was one of those [ __ ]
so something about my elders i'm in
miami i learned how to read maps so when
i got into the triple runs
you had to
get the state and drive it out and then
go to that page and put like a [ __ ]
paper clip on that page in your page and
get the connector
and then i would circle that
and then i would get the directions from
them also they also sent you
would also send you the night of your
gig and how you were going to get there
so to the next gig so how you got there
let's say your week started tuesday
through saturday that's five nights
how you got to
to wenatchee washington that that's your
department that's your problem
once you get to wenatchee tuesday night
you're going to go to the place the palm
springs of
washington you just said it before
yeah yakima washington and then you're
probably gonna go to missoula on [ __ ]
now people like donna richards in those
days and
the other lady they had runs but their
runs were like four hours right
that's not that's amazing
no those other ones those triple runs
they were a 12 hour run kid
and like what happens with uh
weather construction
[ __ ] you accidentally if let's pretend
let's pretend
that there's a gig and it's seven hours
and it's me and ralph and we're pretty
legit with each other and we hear
there's gonna be snow
guys like me around for you girl you
know what time it is no does and
mountain dew yeah might as well no dozer
mountain dew pack the car
back the [ __ ] car and right from the
stage
we get right in the car the hotel knows
we're coming we're comedians
and we'll get there as the snow starts
yeah
by the time we're getting to that city
the snow will start getting hit we're
catching it as we're driving at night
yeah there's different strategies
something silly but how do you find the
weather out at that point was that was
it the tv railroad yeah yeah
they had the radio for all over the
country yeah but we also read the paper
you know that's i still do that i still
like reading the newspaper you're sure
and it's like nobody does it anymore
nobody does that i don't read the l.a
paper i'm not going to lie to you if i'm
not it's got no every once in a while i
pay the 250 for the new york post right
at the airport i rip it off because the
federal charge yeah
you know me i want to be locked up next
to [ __ ] what's his name for a week so
i get some info out of him maybe i'll
call into the podcast
[ __ ] el chapo somebody you never know
[Laughter]
so i wish my memory
was clearer of those times
there's maybe like three or four
prisoners
maybe five that i did time with that i
remember
that from time to time their name will
pop up and i'll look him up on facebook
one kid i found his son
oh wow and we communicated for a while
i don't know what happened there and the
rest of the guys
like i remember atchy
he's a black dude that was like from
indiana i did time with him he was cool
as [ __ ]
spencer antoine i looked up first of all
if i'm 50
spencer's got to be [ __ ] 80
because when i was 25 he was 55
wow right so i was doing time when i was
25
but i love to reconnect with him and
just talk some [ __ ]
all the dudes in the aids unit they got
to be dead
that was 87 that was way before the
medication yeah and they weren't looking
too good then
there was a black dude in the aids unit
that
they they thought he was going to die
bef you know
way but he made it by the time i got out
i got out of the halfway house
he was still there
when i worked with katie siegel on
superior donuts i felt like pulling her
over and going you don't understand how
many times i watch you in the age unit
that [ __ ] show married with children
on sunday nights oh yeah we'd get a
bunch of food from the visitations
and we'd [ __ ] uh
watch married with children like eight
prisoners and the dudes who had the aids
they wouldn't they wouldn't leave their
bedroom yeah they would stay in that
bedroom but we were cool with [ __ ] with
them bro we would knock on their door
and make them come out and eat we used
to have tons of food man
does that mean
it's not me
no it's not me
my phone's off
i'll turn mine off maybe it was mine i
don't know
you know it's kind of weird the
characters i met when i was locked up
yeah right
it's kind of even when i was in rehab i
went to this puerto rican rehab
in boulder like it was
it was such a scam dude you should have
gone to my rehab
man my rehab was nice dog no no this was
nice listen this one you paid them the
money and they just went to you
oh no they were like listening to them
and we'll let you blast off whenever you
want just show up be early for the media
that wasn't mine man that was not real
they worked on your heart over there
how long did you stay in rehab two days
no i wish i had you know i was out of
there two days i would have been out of
there
but my wife was like you're not coming
to my house okay and i'm like what the
[ __ ] and and and they they they gave me
a [ __ ] attitude okay that i'd never
taken that [ __ ] before and i woke up 24
hours day
later okay 24 hours the whole day later
in my own piss okay going i just pissed
myself what the [ __ ] did y'all give me i
do i just smoke weed i wouldn't i was
taking some pills but i wasn't taking
that [ __ ] all right
that's what i got
oh my god
what do you recommend i've been taking
names ralph you might tell me the story
they had you running the airport like
o.j simpson oh my god
oh my god
they had me [ __ ]
it sucks so bad they got it and it's
like you know as mad as my wife was she
she's like
she's like uh hey he's gotta get out the
urn okay so so it was rehab rehab
i'm out okay i'm out about to come back
and maybe take piss test there's nothing
in it again i'm like i told y'all
what the [ __ ] just let's just go
but it was good to get my head right how
many how many how long did you stay in
rehab
34 days
nice
yeah it was great i ran it out to the
insurance said [ __ ] it we're out
insurance build it yeah
they paid for the whole thing uh most of
it yeah it still cost me like 60 grand
when you went to rehab did it help you
you know what it didn't i didn't have i
wasn't addicted to drugs
i was going to be
because i had ptsd
and
and and and i would have been i really
didn't laughing at pbs
because he's a [ __ ] that's right
he's he loves
me i'm just trying to think what he's
got ptsd i was there on many occasions
was it the fall on gardner no no no no
i'll be back get up
was it the time we found the hooker i
mean there was a lot of situations where
you could have gotten paid
no no no it was when i almost died in
tampa but you're [ __ ] such a dick
all right i know
put the sandwich down that's what it
means for ralphie mike you told me that
joke one time you go you got ptsd i mean
put the sandwich down
that's the problem you got
but i i would have been addicted i would
have been i ain't no doubt about it and
i got i got i'm on like soprano and
lamigto now and man i feel phenomenal i
feel phenomenal i'm not [ __ ] bad
about nothing you shouldn't you should
be like a a rap on the commercials for
them man
not a shave club i can do it all day
what's flexor pro 4. uh it's an
antidepressant
and what do you do your dick still get
hard yeah yeah yeah there's got to be a
by the way so no no no
with the lamental uh my [ __ ] are like
twice what they used to be
okay it's it's it makes your [ __ ]
semen load twice as much
all right which means my nuts get a
little sore so i gotta [ __ ] drop a
batch i'm pretty regular okay but
man it's like more volume than it's like
a [ __ ] wet sock or a ladle of pancake
batter up against the wall
it's like it's like it's like stymy when
he got hot with the ink
i'm over here laughing because
there was a two other times when i got
ptsd
when i was there
two other times not 200. the one time he
saw he got up yelling and his head went
into the light bulb and it burns the top
that's not btsd that was hilarious and
sleeping next to jody freddie when she's
passed out and you want to finger that
you got to sit there yeah you can't you
can get off in your pants oh my god
that'll give you a ptsd
me and ralphie would play [ __ ] drink
a pool with jodie and we sit there
praying
for her to just take her clothes off and
blow up oh my god it was tiring
oh my god
[ __ ] crazy days at least i had
20 years of comedy in l.a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up building
just it's so crazy dude you know like i
was at the store last night
and
like the new comics
they don't have a lot of camaraderie
like we do like the same guys that we
used to roll with i saw last night and
it was like i haven't
even though i haven't seen him in a year
it was like i saw him last week you know
what i mean
because we were down so much you know
i uh like mike young okay so i'm mike
young it was good to see mike yeah right
it was good to see brodie stevens last
night no [ __ ]
chris delea had me dying dude you had me
dying with that [ __ ] heart he was
doing something about tupac
that when tupac was dying in vegas
he was taking his last couple of breaths
to cop one up to him
i said tupac quickly
please just give us something tell us
who shot you you saw who shot you and
tupac took a minute and gave the cop the
finger
so he did this whole bit on how you know
would he give the cop the finger i mean
i'm saying if he got shot
so i was back there stoned to the gills
i like sunday nights at the store me too
i like they're all [ __ ] nice yeah
there's no off nights at the store no
more dude it was it was that i had this
i had this
dude at the store yeah i'm the doorman
still to watch your show so that was
ptsd there's a couple times you were me
no it was just [ __ ]
me dying it was me almost dying and not
being able to breathe for 11 days
and no sleep it [ __ ] broke you you
know i mean i couldn't sleep for uh nine
days straight
i was in icu
i
i had this thing breathing for me i
couldn't go to sleep
and so
they were sucking stuff out of my lungs
and it was brutal it was [ __ ] brutal
and that's why
like i can't sleep uh with on white
sheets because it reminds me of the
hospital um i have a really hard time
sleeping because i don't want to if i go
to sleep i think i'll die all right and
so that's why i take the pills now and
now i sleep and i'm not crazy no more
good
where's tony bennett kind of sucker
did i tell you he came to one of my
shows one time absolutely
he's so cool man
real quick two board tack
phil p marcetti
dominic salas you [ __ ] savage
lemon gf
tony i can love uki spooky
andrew wong
and my main [ __ ]
joe
abraham you know what i'm saying hey i
got one i got a fan a buddy of mine his
name's john roberts listen to this guy
he's an ojibwa indian okay on the red
river uh reservation up in northern
minnesota
he has
i think nine kids adopted and he's a
stand-up comic and he's a member of the
church of what's happening now give him
a shout out though [ __ ] yeah john
roberts you're a [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] all right
and uh i worked with him the guy is
great he's [ __ ] phenomenal comic was
that part of the [ __ ] court agreement
no no no dude i the the natives they
like me man
i've raised a bunch of money for him and
uh
and i like man you know i'm glad that
thing happened i didn't know how [ __ ]
the indians were did you know how [ __ ]
they are yes i know i didn't know that i
thought like after like the trail of
tears because i went to i went to school
in arkansas you know they put oh this is
what happened to the indians okay it's
like after the trail of tears i guess i
thought everything just worked out rafi
may let me explain something i grew up
with a cast of characters that would say
things to you
and you would have to look at them and
you wanted to question them
but you knew you were way beyond the
question because they were so real yeah
you had 30 seconds to decide where this
[ __ ] was coming from
and they would say [ __ ] from damn regal
to timmy hollow today timmy holloway
sent me a tweet
and one night it's it's 1984 it's the
height of cocaine
everybody's doing it miami vice is on
you can't talk to a [ __ ] that's
not snorting or smoking bazookas or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
and we're standing in front of corki's
other football i can live i could live
to be 80.
now timmy's brother was my age who's
crazy very funny
and very low-key he don't like no drama
you don't like people with long hair
you don't say you know those [ __ ]
dudes
i will never forget this what about
rhaegar
who was it rhaegar and then rego regular
right wasn't there tonight rhaego at
that time was in love at that time this
was the
the cocaine crew was me
the pelican stinky
and ferny no
ferny was murking but not really he was
mad at me
so that was the original three and then
timmy and then we have you know whatever
blustery always try to find a way to get
a package lubes
veneering was in the circle back then uh
i like veneer very uh he was the driver
we would always work for him and [ __ ]
like that
what the [ __ ] am i talking about here uh
what about rafa fuso ralph of fuso i
grew up with a rapper who's always a bit
different he was an
he was a really nice kid
so we're standing in front of corki's
it's a saturday night it's two in the
[ __ ] morning
and there's a commotion outside we're
inside i'm sorry
and we go outside
and somebody yells it
i might think i am standing there roger
your brother's outside
come on out and roger goes what the [ __ ]
so i walk out there with him and stinky
walks out and
somebody else
and i forget that the little brothers
that say he's like i wanted to see what
the hell you were doing
but the little brother left the car
lights on he left the car around double
parked with the
[Laughter]
go turn the [ __ ] lights off
what's the circus inside
my point being that you know
i grew up with people who would say
shittily and it's always something let
me tell you something roughing me
i love you to death
because the last 20 years you've made it
cool for me to be alive like you've made
it
you've made it this acceptable like when
you used to go on the road and come back
two weeks later yeah i love you because
you got me weed and [ __ ] like that but i
really love seeing it because i really
missed you i figure without you i'm at
the store by myself i'm fighting these
[ __ ] dude we were we were it
was me and you
and that little [ __ ] apartment and it
was just a crazy situation that's where
this began and i would tell you [ __ ] and
we would giggle
and it's just weird that every time you
know this the hospital the ptsd
the [ __ ] you know
yeah i was gonna ask you ralphie how do
you like survive 20 years of joey's like
like there should be like a plaque for
you look like all right yeah longest
running friend okay
all right first of all
uh build up a tolerance to that weed
okay
all right you gotta be ever mine now
have you been a getaway driver yet no no
no no no
no you haven't been a getaway driver yet
i don't believe and coco's not the same
coco he was okay so and and and i mean
while you were well you get the bolivian
flu every once in a while you never
[ __ ] brought it around me no no i do
little bumps in your bathroom right
right but but nothing disrespectful you
know like like if like when i first got
here from houston if you put out coke
right there oh i'd have died all right
but you're always a gentleman i'm always
a gentleman about it
i wasn't even talking about that i was
just talking about like him torturing
you like mentally oh my god
okay all right ladies i hit i broke my
[ __ ] hand i hit a guy at the [ __ ]
air i mean at the uh at the uh post
office because he pushed an old lady
down because she couldn't hear the asian
lady she was an old russian lady all
right and he couldn't hear the nest go
net please okay and so the russian lady
was standing there and this douchebag la
guy
pushed her and she [ __ ] snapped her
[ __ ] arm oh my god yeah right in
front of me so i turned around and hit
the guy and it [ __ ] broke my hand
okay and so
uh i go home i'm [ __ ] talk calling
joey and i'm shook up man i'm
like coco is like a shark if he smells
blood in the water if you're upset about
something that's what he's going for all
right so
so he called me up and go get out of
there get out of there right now the the
police are coming right now because
you knocked the guy out
let's go out the back door i'm i'm
outside and i'll compadre all right go
out the back go right now all right and
i ran out the back door thinking like
that and i didn't have my keys
so i could lock myself out of the back
of gardener so i had to walk all and i
was you know you're fat you're mad okay
you're mad like now i got to walk around
the goddamn front
to get in there but i'm hiding thinking
about doing going down to joshua's house
okay you know what do i do
it's crazy how many getaway drivers
i used that i had to cut a piece in
and it's crazy how many getaway drivers
i did something with
until today they have no idea went down
yeah i think i'm in that group maybe no
no no i can't get away but like no idea
a fast leaving you have no idea and you
know what's crazy
like i remember like four of them now i
don't remember
the good ones when you come back
bleeding and the people like what
happened oh you come back like oj
your hands are cut your eyebrows outside
your shirts ripped yeah and what the
[ __ ] were you oh
i had to go take my shirt out of the
laundry you [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] crazy you're bleeding
from your hand it's gas with death
man i tell you oh my god
when when
i remember the funniest one of the
funniest mornings
we get up and have coffee at like nine
o'clock
and uh and i was i thought you were
gonna be at the house i thought you know
he's got a key just come in before i
could lay down on the futon and go to
bed all right you know maybe take a
shower and go to sleep all right we
didn't give a [ __ ]
all right and joey wasn't there and it
was about 10 o'clock and i made
breakfast and no cocoa what happened so
i go over to gavin boyd's and and
there's there's the there's the the king
of the zombies having bolivian flu like
a [ __ ]
and then and then you're sitting up just
to talk to me trying
and you smell like [ __ ] and coke and
booze
oh my god well i mean a lot of [ __ ] i
love [ __ ] all right and and uh
and gavin boy was like this and his
little [ __ ] dogs
ran up to you and pissed him and pissed
on your head
that little [ __ ] dog
yeah what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're both dead now again
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] man
listen this year is going to be 10 years
since i haven't done that powder
ten years since i haven't done [ __ ]
about it it it's so crazy
a couple days after marilyn died
a couple [ __ ] days after she died i
was like you know what
i'm gonna give it a breather man she was
so sweet
yeah nobody even says anything anymore
that's what killed me people do nobody
mentions freddy's toto
nobody mentions mitch mullaney nobody
mentions
mitch hedberg
except for the [ __ ] take his jokes
nobody remembers nobody
you know it's like it's like they they
pay no respect
and they'd never developed that type of
friendship
a lot of you know people
listen
when i was a kid who were the big people
had died like elvis died when i was
[ __ ] 13
that was craziness
that was a week of craziness in this
country with elvis died
but i still remember freddie prince
shooting himself
wow
that was [ __ ] up man yeah
that was [ __ ] up
a couple months ago i i discussed
freddie prince jr coming on the show and
i just wanted to refresh my memory and i
went on wikipedia and wikipedia that
night
what i remember from that night was bro
i was [ __ ] young ralphie
i was young but i was starting to
not drink
but i was starting to smoke reef and
[ __ ] like that like
and i would smoke reefer and go up town
high and then i would eat pizza at blue
flame pizza which was the spot in those
days
and after you ate the pizza in those
days you had about an hour and a half of
giggles in you
then you'd go home right you know you
got about an hour after you ate the
pizza you're visiting again after the
pizza
then your visine again the smell of
pizza if you put garlic on your pizza
that kills everything that kills the
weed and stuff like that so that was the
that was the [ __ ] uh call when you
got high in those days you know
but i still remember going up down
on the way down somebody because on
fridays was chico and the man yeah
that was such a great show
which was the same show it was a shame
but but
garage but freddie was so goddamn more
funnier than lamont lamont sup all right
like i wanted freddy to be
uh
red fox's son all right that would have
been a hell of a show
and then have shady grady come in okay
yeah i don't know
man shady gray i was out that night i
was out that night
in those days i don't know what my
curfew was maybe 11. like it was a
curfew but not really a curfew
i don't know how old were you
let's pretend 13.
maybe
eighth grade maybe
11 10 30 if i was lurking in the
neighborhood you know
yeah that type of [ __ ] because in those
days
your call time was 10
but if you hung in front of the house
they let you hang to 11.
do you fall i'm saying yes so don't get
off that [ __ ] stoop
don't make me look out this door and
you're playing up the [ __ ] corner
i'll throw all yours out
if you're gonna stay out till 11 i want
you on these [ __ ] stairs and that's
what you did
so some people had like a loose schedule
you know i'm saying
you had a little bit of a loose schedule
i remember the night i found out freddie
prince [ __ ] iced himself
i still remember the walk i had to walk
through a cemetery
that was the first time i cut through
that cemetery because it takes like four
miles off your walk
from up down to downtown there's a back
[ __ ] road back there
and people would say be careful because
there were denver worshipers
but i well i walked back there like
three kids
and i saw some people doing some
santoria
and they made believe they were gonna
chase us but they didn't chase us
the other guys ran i ran like for five
minutes i was tired i'm like like this
you jump in like by 64th street
and you jump out by 51st street
it was a tremendous little [ __ ] uh
but those grave sites were old dog
like there was a lot of gravesites there
from 1860s
the concrete was broken the headstone
was already broken and [ __ ]
you would die
what are you going to do time flies
you know
it's like
comedy has so many people that it just
are gone you know i mean and like
over the 20 years the cast of characters
like that we
knew that were like really good
and like where are they now
you know that like are no longer even in
comedy it's crazy last night i was
standing where you were standing
last night i got to the thing i saw
crystal lee i gave him a hug chris
spencer was up on stage
and i walked into this
yeah i walked in i gave the chinese kid
a hug
hang hold fun
fun whatever yeah he's my man that cool
[ __ ] dude i gotta offer to go to
go to do a bunch of gigs in china
and i'm gonna bring fun fung's a funny
dude man he's a funny dude
and it's like that kid's got heart i
mean he's got a mouth to feed too yeah
yeah he's got mouths to feed but i went
out i gave him a hug i said a little
window girl and i went out in the
hallway where you walk in
and i laid against the wall
and there was nowhere to sit i listened
to crystalia
yeah and i started looking at the
pictures
lee
i saw three people there that i was
super tight with
that have vanished from my life i
couldn't tell you where they are right
what happened to them
it was crazy how many people on that
wall that i was like wow
they used to be here every night
yeah they were doing this they were
doing that
they just disappeared
i just did a show at connecticut mohegan
son
and beaumont bacon sugar
get the [ __ ] out of here gave me a big
hug i gave her a big hug told her i
loved her
told her i was there the night she
rocked the main room man i saw that and
uh that pissed a lot of people off yeah
no no no no no she [ __ ] rocked that
spot yeah
so it's just crazy that you look at
these people and you go [ __ ]
i got a spot at 10 30 at the store how
lucky am i
20 years later
i'm still doing a sunday night spot at
the [ __ ] store and now the difference
between 20 years and now is
that 20 years ago this room would have
been 60 people less and a great room
don't get me wrong it would have been a
great educational but the time we'd get
on because we get bumped down you know
first of all
you hear andrew's coming okay and
eddie's coming i wouldn't i wouldn't
nobody said
let me explain to you how to mine the
joey diaz work
okay number one at that time i was an
addict lee let me explain some tealy
you want to learn from the jew
god put you in the bite right jew's hand
there was a way to make money at the
store there's a couple angles to make
money at the store
you could get the main room which i
never got not because i didn't uh
want it every once in a while she gave
me a saturday night in there and that
put an extra 100 buck 50 in your pocket
but you didn't get rich in that you
didn't get rich in the ore you get 15 a
spot
but she cut me a deal one night
she goes do you want a host
and she goes how about you
work the door
from seven to ten i'll give you 25 bucks
and then you host
from 10 to close and i'll give you
another 25 bucks
i go that's great but that's a lot of
walking
for 25 bucks
so i got an idea i took andrew's phone
number down
i took eddie griffin's number down
and i took joe rogan's number down okay
and i took anybody who had bumping
privileges numbered them
whether it was paul morty
all of them
yes sunday afternoon
because listen
i could go to the store on sunday the
guy who sold coke worked the door
so guess how i worked it i would get on
stage do my tent yeah
pull up
and through two dice glasses eddie or
paul and that's an hour easy i could go
do a few bumps have a few cocktails get
the party started and right before they
get off i go to don barris and go
guess who the host is the rest of the
night who me and i'd give him the
microphone and i'd be out of there by 11
15 with a package
i picked up this half a yard i hosted i
did comedy i did my job for the night
yeah who's better than me
strong that was my most favorite night
at the store with sunday nights because
i'd host till 11 30 though dude i used
to love sundays because we would
i'd always have cookouts behind the
apartment you know even though i had a
studio and it was i mean it was a
murderer's role of comedians at those
[ __ ] barbecues all right and then you
cook the turkey at four in the morning
or something
so good though
can you do something crazy like that i
know one night we went over there and
your buddy
i pulled we pulled over he was talking
to a hooker and then when he got back
he said he was a friend of his and [ __ ]
that's what there's a lot of hookers on
yeah
jesus christ from fairfax oh my god
a little bit down in those days boxy
white chicks lee it was crazy foxy
you were pulling then like some black
girls that stabbed somebody till this
day till this day after 10 o'clock what
a lot of people don't know and if you do
it there's a cop there they'll nail you
oh yeah [ __ ] you they will my gardener
yeah
the street after this
when it starts it's where it starts if
you make a left
or right if you're headed to it if
you're headed to the comedy store
and you make a left before fairfax and
there's a cop date you will get pulled
over though you get a ticket dude it's
like 200 something dollar ticket if you
make a left on those streets i did that
because of me too me too i got cause i
was [ __ ] going to see doug and he
totally turned around so i [ __ ]
turned down curse on like you would to
go to doug's apartment and [ __ ]
it's like boom we pull over and then
he's laughing at me as he walks the two
blocks down to his [ __ ] apartment and
we were just at the coaching horses he
was just shitty and just wanted to ride
[ __ ]
how they got me how they get you this is
a classic
joey diaz
2005.
coke story i forgot all about that
you're going to love okay i hear me i'm
sorry i go out you know you got some
stars over there or something you know
me in those days
i used to go out early
did get my uh
started 7 30. there'd be two parties
that's how you had to do it in those
days
it would be two remember i had to pick
up an envelope for tomorrow's envelope
for the night
there was always something a cell phone
a pocketbook there was always something
at the coffee store
so
it's like a monday nightly
i get a package
my wife is home
she's my girlfriend at the time i'm
living with her
on schrader
and i got a package i go home the
package is okay
but for some reason that monday night
the coke wasn't sticking
it wasn't getting me high enough
so i called a few people to pick up a
pack of jesus christ
there's no packages nowhere
this guy's sleeping this guy's doing
this
this guy's doing that
finally i go oh
i know he's got a [ __ ] package
and for some reason
i did the same thing
i passed the guy's house
and i went to make a u-turn i figured
i'd pull into 7-eleven
and they [ __ ] nailed me down the
corner
and no no no no no no
didn't even nail me down the corner they
pulled me over right in the 7-eleven dog
how about that one for you wow they
pulled me over right when i saw them i
pulled into the 7-eleven to make believe
like i had just [ __ ] up right they
walked right in there and said can we
talk to you for a second like
listen
you just broke the thing why
i was coming in here to get water and
something else now i'm coming down on
the blow
i'm on the tail end but i'm manageable
but i'm still a little on the [ __ ]
cocaine
i'm talking to these two cops and
they're like all right do us a favorite
show as id
i got no idea this is terry clark's car
i'm on sunset it's one in the morning
yeah i got 60 bucks with a coke man up
the corner
and that's all i need just let me go
right now and i'll never make a left
turn ever yeah right
right forever
rights forever you'll never see me in
this neighborhood late night again
and i [ __ ] started talking to the
guys i'm sorry bro i told you god
and i gotta throw you in jail somebody
has to come and get you
and all of a sudden
a drunk dude
walks over
and he goes joey diaz oh [ __ ]
and he gives me a hug i don't have the
handcuffs on you
and the cop looks up and goes you know
him he goes [ __ ] yeah that's joey d is
the longest shot and both cops look at
me and they go how you doing buddy
let's start talking to me now i go
what's going on i go listen i just left
the house
i just went to 7-eleven just to get what
i was dying something was going on and i
think all right just go straight home
don't let us catch you drive without
your license
i went right to martell
i [ __ ] shot the left i pick up a gram
and i went home and i never made a
[ __ ] left turn again on [ __ ]
sunset no never
[ __ ] they were gonna tow my [ __ ]
car and everything though they do that
on melrose too jack
not always you can't turn after 11 on
some parts really yeah
i think santa monica too
like not stanley but on the other side
of fairfax
those houses back there those gays
they're like nah
you don't bring your party back here all
right you want to turn a trick and suck
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] bathroom go for it
abby's down the block you know what i
mean
that's how they get in there you know
they're gonna get the taste of dick out
of their mouth with that brazilian food
next door that bossa nova okay
i don't know where it is now
i don't really know where it is but it
was on santa monica it was all santa
monica
when i first lived here i lived with the
stripper in the trailer
and for a while i would stay with doug
and then for a while i would stay with
her
and you have to move the trailer all
around
and we lived next to a park
that if you went there in the daytime
like if i could remember where it was it
was hollywood it was right around
beverly and
maybe curse on or something like that
and it's it's it's probably a [ __ ]
building now yeah at the time it was
this little park
in the daytime they had benches and you
could walk up the stairs
and they had like a little swimming area
dog at [ __ ] three in the morning
that place would turn into sex central
in those days
so i would be sleeping with carol in the
[ __ ] trailer
and you could hear the men
this is 1990 [ __ ] seven guys
and they were [ __ ] right outside like
male hookers i guess they were
you could hear them having sex
right outside dog that [ __ ] lasted like
three nights for me and like i couldn't
sleep i couldn't sleep that's how you
sleep with that noise i couldn't sleep
with that [ __ ] noise and there was no
women out there
there was no guys and women it was all
every time we looked out there there was
two men having sex
the one guy choking the other one it was
i just remembered this [ __ ] see this is
the [ __ ] that's maybe your ptsd huh
maybe you have ptsd
are you [ __ ] late oh my god i got
acid from that last [ __ ] church
what's happening right now
what you can do right now goddammit i'll
go get the snake okay don't look at the
yellow all right
somebody started really if you don't
that i know i got people i got ptsd just
you do
without a doubt you don't
the multiple things
no the one in particular the one
the one that
wants me to this day was
my godfather
there's times i think about [ __ ]
paying a private investigator look for
my godfather
so i could eliminate it once and for all
he was a [ __ ] at the end dog
it was ugly
and he was relentless
he was relentless ralphie
you know
i would i would when i left north bergen
it was uh december of 84
and i would keep in touch with three or
four buddies
and dog i would hear [ __ ] from them
that i could have called [ __ ]
or i could have believed
and then leah is late i smartened up
like why why would they [ __ ] be
talking this [ __ ]
and then i had another friend my first
daughter
jackie
her godparents
the father
uh the godfather
pete he was a [ __ ] serious white dude
that i grew up with
pete was italian no iris no none of that
mafia [ __ ]
pete was a serious [ __ ] white dude
that knew his [ __ ] before i made any
moves in those days i go to pete
if pete goes to the cops today
pete could throw me in jail for 30
[ __ ] years
from 1980 to 1985 i told pete everything
i did
whether he agreed with it or not whether
he was a close friend of ours or not
i told because i i always had to have
somebody
i was a hundred percent honest with
yeah like i've been that guy for a long
time yeah no matter what you came to me
in those days and said to me
like if you came to me no says say joey
tell me that you didn't rob the comedy
store yes i [ __ ] did
i was that guy like if anybody else
asked me i'd go now
hey that was weird he had a his
sweatshirt like he was nah
that seems like a liability to me
doesn't it what's that buddy telling
somebody
you gotta um burn your heart listen bro
you have no judgments
that's what real friends are you did
in those days
you have people that they come up to you
listen man
if you don't want the answer
don't ask the [ __ ] question right
that's true but okay
i when i was 14 i got one of the
greatest lessons in my life and it stuck
with me
his name was jimmy bender senior
he once told me something that [ __ ]
just
stuck with me like i started hanging out
with him and swimming in this pool i was
friends with his son and when i went to
the track and he goes listen
if you tell me the truth
i got your back
but if you lie to me i can't help you
and that always that always stuck with
me
i always remembered what that was
intended for
and then years later i saw him kick a
junkie in the stomach and drag him out
and say the guy was gonna die in this
house so i know you meant business to
understand me
but at the same time
the way i was growing up in those days
my friends were gonna take heat from me
okay
like let's pretend
um
let's just throw some names out here
because we know
let's pretend hari
was a
ari shafia who's ari today people like
ari army's a great guy
yeah let's pretend i robbed a kilo for
mari
all right like joe diaz today
robbed a kilo from harvey
and ari had two guys working for him
steve runs easy and somebody else whose
balls they gonna bust every day
they gotta bust ralphie's ball
they're gonna bust these balls like
where's joey have you heard from him
tell joy when we see him we're gonna
break his [ __ ] head
you know guess what you're gonna hear
from those every time you go out late
and you see those guys gonna come up to
you and go you ever hear from your pal
what you mean to tell me is you never
heard from your pal no
you're full of shitly you're a piece of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
you piece of [ __ ] how long can you
tolerate that for
before you say you know i know where he
is
well to be honest really if i lie to you
you're not gonna take that from me no
more in my mind
if you're a good friend why [ __ ] it up
with a lie
if he's not a friend who the [ __ ] is he
to [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
but if they're a good good good solid
friend and you come to me and you go
joey
i want to ask you but i don't
and i already know what you want to know
i'll tell you
yeah
i had to
whatever and you'll look at me and go
jesus christ
all right we'll fix it you know that's
that's the difference
like then i saw ralphie walking across
the street
from the japanese place and they called
the cops on me
at the [ __ ] dublin i saw ralphie and
i looked him straight he's like i gotta
showcase for cbs yeah later
push him
tell him that you're not doing this
season
his career yeah go get this it would
have been go get the [ __ ] go get the
[ __ ] go get the [ __ ] voyager the
forerunner
yeah i got the four rounds
that's me at the forum yeah
my nephew has it now
are you sorry [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] great still running 300 000
400 and something thousand yeah i was on
it i totally 400 a toyota are you
listening to me
i had a forerunner that i was a comedian
in i'm in 1996
okay
toyota 4runner it's
21 years old it's got over about a half
a million miles on it
and it's still going jack
still going you don't even see those
anymore no
no
my nephew had it repainted
because i had shined it up so much that
i'd
created swirls in it from shining it so
much
with [ __ ] not the right stuff
and uh so he had it painted and it
[ __ ] looks great takes us to the
razorback games he's happy his [ __ ] he's
got a little boy he's one he's [ __ ]
it's a it's like that car
you know that [ __ ] westling would
bang his wife in and [ __ ] leave
condom rappers all over the place
oh god jesus all right
you know
that same car
my nephew's got but when i and i had a
good parking spot too man good parking
spot and i was gonna walk right in and i
had a showcase with cbs they were all on
my ass
and you're like ralphie go get the
[ __ ] car and i'm like this is this is
serious
okay and i was halfway in this in the
middle of the street and i'm so fat that
i can't i can only wear warm-ups so i'm
always trying to [ __ ] everybody thought
i was trying to be black this is the
only thing that fit i didn't afford it i
got them for free it was big daddy big
daddy we all wore big daddy i lived up i
told them to leave for a year and a half
that's all i wore without a doubt i
wanted coke i just wore their outfits i
just washed everywhere
i wore it everywhere why were they
giving you for your outfits because they
wanted
i had that [ __ ] for years yeah
they gave me a big daddy jersey
that i wore once a year once a week for
[ __ ] three years
they gave me a big daddy dallas cowboy
shirt wow like i said big daddy but
blue
or something like that i had some great
big daddies man i still got it i'm still
got it yeah and you know what it's still
some of my favorite [ __ ] to wear i
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] it's great what
does that happen they sold i don't know
what happened to them they were so good
to us
so many they gave it they got into the
movies because they gave it to the black
comic
and how he got into the movies was
barbershop yeah the first barber shop he
wore a big daddy on there so he was
their first big
client they had other people i wore it
on tv
i was trying to work on the big uh best
damn sports show yeah
i really did too they were good people
yeah they were great and
philly yeah and um
i uh
uh i did that i wore them and i got big
daddy to sponsor a bunch of i was doing
those low rider magazine car shows
around the country
and i got them to sponsor that so i was
getting my airfare paid okay wearing big
daddy all these places and they were
selling out i put them in my video when
i went to iraq i wore big daddy all
right and it was phenomenal
they i mean they make they make shirts
they could breathe so much it was 135
degrees and my titties didn't smell like
vinegar you know what i mean that's
pretty [ __ ] impressive i probably
[ __ ] was great [ __ ] i probably had
big daddy clothing lurking until about
2008
when i moved out of hollywood that was
the end of the big daddy i had a couple
t-shirts
i had a few sweat jackets or whatever
yeah
i didn't even know they were around
anymore
nobody had them i couldn't wear sweats
anymore the mafia thing was over with
yeah so there was no reason to wear
sweats anymore so that was the end of
that i don't even know what happened to
the rest of that [ __ ] they were great
people
yeah it's so nice they're still around
doing something see in those days a lot
of people would start those companies
they would blow up and then they'd sell
them yeah and then somebody else would
pay absorb it up yeah and they'd pick
them up and buy three or four t-shirt
companies yeah and now combine them and
do something have you have you got in
contact with this uh
winston
company no it's a designer it's he's a
he's an actor he's a fat actor
and he sent me a link to it dude i just
got this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] amazing
every bit of it is [ __ ] phenomenal
i'll get you hooked into it
man flavor it's so great it's like
really super high quality stuff that i
can't find anywhere else
yeah
texas is okay if you're a fat dude you
got to go to texas lord jesus that's the
only place you go man you know what man
it's such a shame because like i
explained on stage last week
in texas if i'm a 2x here
in texas i'm an extra large right so if
i buy clothes in texas and i got extra
large i go jesus christ i lost weight
you feel good about yourself time to eat
time to eat they don't [ __ ] around they
switch the labels on you
so you go to texas you buy a 3x you're
swimming like a [ __ ] thing you're
like what happened to this i could use
this in 3x no
because they make the clothes bigger and
la they make them smaller get a 2x in la
i guarantee
you walk into any walmart in la you
don't fit in 2x walk into a [ __ ]
houston yeah you'll be swimming in a
one-action jesus christ i lost weight no
they make the clothes bigger
so every of those marshalls
all that [ __ ] if you're a 2x like me
becomes fair [ __ ] game now
if i usually walk into marshalls there's
no clothing for me but in texas
marshalls has clothing for uncle joey
and [ __ ] don't move don't move don't
move it's despite is the best bee right
there
no no
don't mess him up
come on man
that's the job that's how he did it
it was great it's going to be a great
one people are going to go
they're going to make gifts of this
stuff
we have a star here no thank you no no
you ate
where are you performing the next few
weeks my brother
uh harrah's las vegas
how long um
this
thursday friday saturday at 10 o'clock
and then next thursday friday saturday
at 10 o'clock
and then
then i'm in san antonio at lol
and
i can't remember
that's like the next three weeks
but like i'm gonna be also coming back
here
um uh
next sunday and monday and tuesday hang
out with my kids and do some meetings
and uh and then the next week is
father's day so i'm gonna be around
maybe i don't know maybe if you and your
family maybe sunday dinner or someplace
you know we maybe go back to that
italian place i told you about like it's
old school italian uh that uh tony's
bella italiano
on uh [ __ ] uh magnolia
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what he goes to eat
[ __ ] like that that's where i'm going to
stay for now
you know what oh my god mango
i'm happy you're doing well ralphie i'm
happy
you know before the podcast and i know a
lot of people listen to this podcast
you've been divorced or separated
and you know uh while it's happening you
think it's the end of the world right
and it's a pain that doesn't go away for
three years and
either the attorneys could keep it going
or you like with me i just squashed it
i said one day you know what man i want
to do comedy
that's it i just want to do [ __ ] kind
of like
you know what i came to the conclusion
i was fighting for a never-ending war
because at the end
i couldn't cover this bradley uh
whatever your [ __ ] name is ralphie
ralphie
i'm stoned too i know baby i couldn't
cover the spread robbie and that was the
worst feeling in the world to know
but also the best feeling in the world
when i moved back to
when i left living with george when he
was junked up yeah and his grandmother
and i was having a great time
and i was really learning comedy i saw
legos i'm all that night at two in the
morning and i had figured it out
i gotta move somewhere where i could do
a lot of open mics
take my time just get time
and i could do something with this
[ __ ] comedy [ __ ] i've been doing it
in new york it's been working men's and
men's
anywhere i go has always been receptive
come back
so i'm on to something i don't know what
it is in a month i might play the flute
i don't know what it is but i'm gonna
stick this out i got no money
i got a little job i.e from week to week
yeah why not have a good time my way
every night i do comedy i bump into
somebody they give me a pill
we do a bump i drink two cocktails
because they give you two drink tickets
i'm having the time of my [ __ ] life
yeah i wanted a family i wanted to be
married i thought that's what i wanted
once i got on that stage and i got
hooked
it was all over but to shout
i walk in one day she says she doesn't
want to be married no more it was like
god said here you go [ __ ]
this is what you want you're [ __ ]
lunatic
and i went for it ralphie you gave us a
[ __ ]
and that's what we're enjoying right now
we're enjoying those triple runs that we
did we're enjoying you did those other
brothers that that dude c.w
c.w kendall i told him to suck my dick
because see how he gave he used to give
you a long week yeah then the week
before the gig kind of done it two days
yeah but it was like wednesday and
saturday
and then [ __ ] 12 hours apart you had
to put yourself up for two days it was
[ __ ] amazing people
or or you know what you would do is
you would stay in your car lee
okay and and and sleep in your car until
like 2 30 3 o'clock
all right and then
take the hotel room okay
and you would stay there at that one for
a full 24 hours
all right which basically meant you got
two days for the one day
because you went there early you just
stayed in your car you stayed up or you
slept in your car that's what i would do
and then you get free breakfast i'd i'd
[ __ ] them up on the free breakfast oh my
god i make blt's left and right because
i stole a [ __ ] pound of bacon i you
think i'm lying to you i ain't lying not
one bit blt's fruit uh but [ __ ] you on
the cantaloupe i don't like that all
right and uh
uh uh just stay in there and then they
had afternoon thing and then get them in
the morning
[ __ ] eat up a bunch and then go do so
you only had to do one night actually
pay for but you'd go pick a town to do a
spot in you know like dallas or
oklahoma city denver
uh austin you know you'd [ __ ] around
find something to do
and then pick up 50 bucks or something
it might cover a hotel room might not
you might not
i worked for shirley buying them too out
of there she was great
um
and uh but man those tribble runs
[ __ ] bananas
[ __ ] bananas oh man and i remember
one time he booked me the headline
and uh he also booked chris alpine the
headline and chris evan was so mad
okay
he was like i want i want to go up
last and i'm like well
what's up i'm a filthy dirty
[ __ ] and if it means for a
second this guy's not gonna pay me
headline pay [ __ ] you uh you won't be
able to follow me and he he went up and
i didn't give a [ __ ] i didn't stand
there to listen and i got all mad about
that and i just he was all clean and i
just went up and just trashed him for
the first 15 20 minutes
oh god tribble got lit up on that one
and then and then like chris alpine's uh
manager was another woman that booked
gigs up there
pat wilson and she blackballed me
because i was dirty okay
[Laughter]
yeah she black mommy because she managed
to cross out fine and he got blown out
yeah one time people the people that
were talking about pat wilson and
they were big figures in her life man
at one time
we would call these people every monday
and beg them for work
and if they sent this to mars
we just we would take the mission it's a
crazy thing to sit here
and laugh and think about those times
man you're the king of the greyhound
you know you you called part read on
monday afternoon
dog i figured it out
i figured it out when i started selling
screws online bar
i would have to be there at five in the
morning i would basically leave the
store
and park my car in those days and jerk
off
and go into this place at five
and i would start [ __ ] emailing and
faxing people roger paul yeah the
buffalo funny bone
[ __ ] yeah miami improv yep the fall you
have no [ __ ] idea my friend yeah the
birmingham alabama club oh yeah startup
houston laptop and the yes spot i didn't
get a comedy showcase
they got a fax mug for joey every monday
yeah here's my events
and and if you left them wide open you
wouldn't get booked so you'd have to put
in where you kind of wanted to be
those things like this
book like this and you knew yeah these
dates were kind of close so you'd call
them and beg and go hey i got this let
me have it all right you know you you
manage it you know you you had to work
the angles if you if you went to comedy
like well i'm a nice guy and i'm going
to send a headshot and a tape a vhs
they wouldn't give a [ __ ]
okay you had to be something different
you know you had to be funny because and
there was no [ __ ]
youtube no [ __ ] it was vhs they couldn't
they couldn't check your [ __ ] uh
yeah your your webpage yeah so you could
tell them listen i'm gonna be in austin
this week why don't you give me the week
before right exactly it was brilliant
yes hey it's an amazing thing to learn
on your own then you hear that there's a
thursday in beaumont you're like [ __ ]
somebody hey i'm going to be in town all
right and you just shut up and you start
calling other comedians it's like we the
internet was like just your [ __ ]
rolodex you know you go hey dougie where
the [ __ ] are you at okay hey give me a
feature week because i'm [ __ ]
co-headlining with [ __ ] oh my god what
was that guy's name
um
and not um god damn it
um
[ __ ] he's an arkansas comic
crazy it's crazy i forget god damn it
and he was [ __ ] bananas that guy was
so much fun or captain rowdy or
something like that you know you see
these guys and you're just like
wow these are [ __ ] boom and and now
they're even gone it's it's but it was
all of like hey i need help getting this
date you know and you so you go you know
if you wanted to be in in the uh
zanies you had to tell people that you
were doing uh creative gigs in the
southeast you know hey i'm gonna be
there give me a spot all right boom you
know hey can i stay at your condo for
extra what an education it was as a
feature act yeah go from having a day
job
to booking gigs now for yourself and
you're adding up all these gigs and if
you add it up you're still not making
anything close to what you're making
yeah but you'll accept it you figure out
a way to make it work you know what that
bedroom in the back that's an office
that's going to become a bedroom i'm
ready yeah this is where you're right
now this is way before a b and
you
b
dog
the library and put a piece of paper up
bedroom for rent
split the utilities and [ __ ] and these
guys you learn how
like from 93 and a half
to 95 i think i'd become a comic shack
unbear nothing
that car was going to fall apart
at any time
and for me to go on the road where i was
going in those days
but every road gig i got
something always happened
yeah i met this [ __ ] dude man in my
life
that's why i sit there and i go someday
i'm gonna pass away
and if there's a real [ __ ] god or
whatever they talk about
the people that i saw that helped me
were angels that god sent when i was
like a my head was a good direction i
just need a little bit of help i met
this white dude in boulder bro i can't
remember what his name is you know me
ralphie may he keeps me awake some nice
because i wish i'd give him a big hug
right now i was going through a personal
[ __ ] hell
i was living in a one-bedroom basement
i was starting to do comedy hbo had used
me
to open up for carlos muncilla and jimmy
abeda
in four different cities and
it was the summer of maybe 94.
i'm barely paying rent snorting coke and
eating
there was no car payment the car looked
like the car that they
killed michael corleone's boyfriend
and godfather won
if
look that's what it looked like
the [ __ ] back window was missing
it was about monday tuesday
let me tell you something
i was taking six-hour drives on that
[ __ ] car poor about until this
down
what i was doing for 250 dollars in
those days i was driving to cheyenne
wyoming or
somewhere in wyoming and when you get
there it's beautiful when you get on
stage dog that's three feet of snow
yeah
and you have you have to be
from cheyenne you had to be
in um
uh bozeman
okay
and uh or jackson hall
okay and you you you had to go through
three foot of snow and so you you knew
it'd take twice as much time
and if you're lucky you'd find a guy
shoveling and and get behind him so now
you're going 25 miles an hour and so you
just double the time so you don't sleep
you just take no doughs and drink
mountain dew and get a gatorade and piss
in the gatorade bottle what about the
night you get the 250
and you need every [ __ ] dime of it
you got to take it home yeah but on the
way in you walk in this beautiful you
walk out and there's a foot of snow
that's really coming down
you don't have the money to [ __ ] get
a hotel right and you don't want to take
the chance to drive oh just shovel
yourself out and go behind the
supermarket
and get a blanket i used to have a
blanket in that truck
i
lisa
hear the line nobody at least i had i
didn't one time i was going to tell you
i got one just like i know you did you
had that toyota yeah man
yeah guys i could name i could tell i
slept in my car so much 100 times i
slept in a car in [ __ ] two years yeah
easy easy easy being a comedian no and
not giving a [ __ ]
you can wake up anywhere and get stabbed
in the [ __ ] neck dog without a doubt
oh my god i would go behind hotels
i would go behind warehouses i was
falling asleep you have no idea when
you're tired how your mind works i was
falling asleep
at the wheel okay and i'm in
close to mount shasta okay
and there's scenic overlook and i pull
in there
okay i go to sleep in the back of my
truck all right it's like it's like 50
degrees
all right and i got my pistol and i'm in
my sleeping bag
i wake up and there's eight inches of
goddamn snow
and it's now like 16 degrees and i'm i'm
blue
my face is [ __ ] blue all right
i don't know where the [ __ ] i don't know
how to get out of there the road is
completely [ __ ] all right and i've
still i've got to be in with nancy
washington okay and in
14 hours
okay
you know i've got i don't know where the
[ __ ] roads are closed and not closed
okay
or you know and you have to cut through
[ __ ] white's pass
okay god damn [ __ ] that white's pass
all right you drive up and you're like
9 000
10 000 feet
something like that
and and it's there's no weather at the
bottom up there it's a [ __ ] blizzard
okay and so you have to you have to
fight going to sleep because if like i i
had to shut my car off because i was
gonna get carbon monoxide poisoning okay
i had to say i had a car dog that every
time i got in it i'd have to write a
suicide note right because the smoke
would go into the [ __ ] cockpit yeah i
would get a headache after 20 minutes
i'd have to pull over get out of the car
walk i wish
this was a joke no it would take me from
portland to seattle it's supposed to
take you two hours it would take me five
hours because i had to stop every 20
minutes and get out of the [ __ ] car
that's what i did for a hundred dollars
in those days yeah i would drive to
seattle to a mexican restaurant in
portland
for donna richards
and i would do the 125 gig and drive
back to [ __ ] seattle
you're crazy
man how about how many how many roger
paul giggs did you do
with with the uh
uh
with the uh
uh the
the the female comedian that wore a
wedding dress
his wife or his ex-wife
i think one in all those years oh really
oh my god i got on a string
and man wow that was an extreme show
i'll tell you what you do learn about
comedy that ralphie knows
is that sometimes things happen
and you scratch your head for five
[ __ ] years
like i was just talking to you
and i did there used to be another
company
that used to do comedy when i [ __ ]
started there was dana and doug mcgraw
the phenomenon and i sent them a tape
and they made me a co-headliner when i
couldn't even see
they said we love your stage presence
and they got me a gig as a feature which
paid like 145
and i went up there and again
this is when i needed every dime
after the gig i got out of there it was
and i didn't drink i said i'm not gonna
drink because i gotta sleep on the
street today
they paid me in cash it's gonna cost me
22 to get home
maybe five for a subway
veggie and cheese with a soda
i'll get home with 110 dollars i need
every [ __ ] diamond is
there's no hotel in my [ __ ] future
in those days i had a trunk and that uh
corolla
and there was everything in there lee a
two blankets a pillow
[ __ ] snow boots
regular shoes hiking boots
explosives a flare
a canteen filled with water you [ __ ]
name it and it was in there
that if you moved one of them
it was amazing i had everything in that
scotch [ __ ] tight i had to stick
across the back
i would hang clothes back there
so i could hide back there if i had to
sleep in the car i figured out a way to
kick the front seat and push it forward
i had it i had a jacked up dog i fitted
a thing
my buddy was a half a [ __ ] engineer in
boulder he was a genius he made me a
thing so i could put on the bottom so
where you put your feet now wasn't there
it became part of your mattress
i had that little car going man got
unbelievable the places i slept yeah man
i would walk into hotels and eat the
free breakfast brush my teeth [ __ ] yes
exactly my face
walk past the front guard walk into the
hotel league
take a tremendous [ __ ]
piss
wipe my ass really good because it got
dirty overnight in that [ __ ] car
i would brush my teeth wash my hair
push my eyebrows back
gargle and then have everything in my
jacket
and then i'd walk like i owned the joint
yeah what's for breakfast here this
morning for 9.95 did you stay at the
hotel last night yeah what room
60 280
lisa
all right go and sit down so of course
you [ __ ] like 890 a [ __ ] table for
everything you could eat
are you crazy after you slept in a car
all night you eat one of everything
cantaloupe
rice krispies
you eat a bagel you eat a cinnamon bun
those buffets you go to lee
you eat one of everything yeah right you
go you can go back for pill
you just slept in a car
to do your [ __ ] dream your diet
really doesn't matter
that's what killed me you died at that
point
really doesn't matter i remember going
back one time and somebody going joey
you're putting on weight so i put a
basketball with me on the road
and i forced myself to go in the back of
every hotel in the parking lot and run
around with a basketball i did that for
about three months you know that's how
retired i was
so where are you going to be the next
couple of weeks
i'm going to be at harrah's at the uh
the beautiful casino uh jerez
you know what i like about it i gotta be
honest the most thing i really like
about it is there's no shiny shirt half
of [ __ ] over there okay
uh it's like a bunch of real people
okay it's 15
[ __ ] blackjack you can have a good
time drink pretty good booze
okay they've got great restaurants
there's a ruth chris if you want steak
meat i mean come on who's better than
that and
you gotta
okay listen hercules i got a five
bedroom house that uh rented me with a
good ass pull and everybody has allergic
to listen to me let
done i'll put him at the beautiful
caesar's palace we don't want to stand
there being big is what i'm telling no
good god no
i don't stand airbnb
and i don't need it i don't either i
don't either i don't even mind you're
going to manage in las vegas
what are you drinking champagne
champagne cocktail champagne
jumping coconuts i'm staying on airbnb
and blankets
[Laughter]
you know leigh's one of those guys in
vegas
that you get them high
yeah it's really it's real you know lee
thinks like
when lee was allowed at the south point
lee was very interesting to me
because
at least age i didn't like las vegas at
all yeah i took a hating for las vegas
when i was 22
and i said i don't need this place
i'm from new york city where i could do
this well
i got to walk around with cameras
i got to walk around with cameras and
they watch in their bathrooms they watch
everything immediately for me to get
down for me to come to you same 84 i had
to know i could snort in peace
i could go to a bar and gack out like i
used to do in houston
but you can't even talk anymore i go to
that island park in
no no no no yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
no no the [ __ ] other bar where
you get jaundice they had no windows
that bar there i used to walk in there i
couldn't even [ __ ] talk
but anyway i make a [ __ ] long story
short i know what the long [ __ ] story
shot was
it's uh what's up lee when i was a lot
of the south point yeah lee was online
as a stop point it was interesting
because
we would finish up a show
we would eat something we'd get high
and lee would look like you know okay
i get it he's tired i'm tired
and the next day i'd hear a tremendous
story
how he got up at two
brushed his hair and came down he won
till five
and at 5 30. he bumped into a friend who
put bad luck on him and he went back to
the table how's that
and he ended up losing and we ended up
losing what he won
plus 100 out of his pocket now he's
salivating from the mouth
because he's jewish he goes back up to
the room
he washes himself he bangs without he
calls his girlfriend and he refused for
the last temptation of christ
he's got this weird way of gambling
then he's telling me how good he is he's
johnny bananas
i stalk him my steak in my yard or two
he blows it in two minutes he got beat
up
like a [ __ ] like something
so this day he blames me
i won my first couple hands and he lived
and i walked away so it's my fault i've
never been nobody's lucky
i never have
put him in the bathroom about eight
weeks ago he started a new career he got
books
he took
he took a [ __ ] course on hypnotics
[Music]
i go everywhere with that he took a
course you know by the way
uh i've had okay thank you church
for uh taking me in and loving on me you
guys come to my shows
and after the show room
i'm you know
downstairs maybe having a
delicious bloodwise product okay you
know maybe maybe enjoy myself a little
bit before i go home
and
you guys come up to me and you're like
look at the yellow ralphie where's that
goddamn bracelet we [ __ ] love that
and and
and it's because of this i've gotten
tons of fans
and and they've come in and they've
loved me and i just say thank you i am
very humbled by y'all the [ __ ] church
is for real dude
they do not [ __ ] around in in denver i
had uh i had like five guys uh go dude
i'm from the church and they brought me
reefer okay i had to leave your family
dude i i i love you
man they'll give you a buffalo oh my god
buffalo they come
running
houston
houston's all the time in nashville oh
my god every time i'm at zane that's my
home club okay
every time i'm there
every time 20 or 30 guys are like
man we love you on the church
and it's just like it's so cool
man it's like it's like it's like the
thing that we had
is like
that is like just going out
you know what i mean and and i'm i'm
just trying to distract now
because coco's really getting into his
[ __ ] left nut all right
i think he might be ready to pop and sit
and [ __ ] uh
getting like stuck your nut gets stuck
on your underwear
you know me undies is banging
from that i have short time
so it [ __ ] it up
all right let me read this out we'll get
the [ __ ] out of here can't believe
you're just leaving that there don't
forget
don't forget this weekend you [ __ ]
savage it's starting thursday night
i'm at the brea improv embraer my
[ __ ] home club
thursday one show of death
leo be there we're picking up the ship
and the new stars
tomorrow he'll be there breaking his
record of 3 000. whoa putting him on a
skateboard and sending him back
now he'll be there lee ain't breaking
his record unless he gets paid from now
and he's doing personal appearances
if you like to bring lee fly him out to
your party
leo eat [ __ ] five thousand milligrams
get the money's right okay
we don't give a [ __ ] at this point in
the game ten dollar ten dollars a
milligram no we gotta lower that don't
be stupid
don't be stupid you want them to win
yeah don't be greedy
don't be greedy what do you think is
reasonable hey man no you might get
lucky somebody might know how to
barbecue
for you i'm saying
yeah don't forget on this one i need a
little taste you've had like 19 ventures
does a five dollar bill fall my way out
never never not at all nothing they even
wear this big he makes anything that's
the tip and he makes a thousand he makes
thousands of dollars this [ __ ] guy
selling [ __ ] and everything he sells
hats he's a savage
he's a savage look at him he's smiling
over there
[Laughter]
he still owes me for the gambling
three times
and all three times i lost my investment
yeah right he comes back not even with a
five dollar bill he's been
he's bringing garlic fry from the casino
casinos got great [ __ ] food yes they
do that [ __ ] steakhouse is [ __ ]
amazing that seafood bar is good i like
the one harris better on that one but i
got to be honest with you you got sushi
right there you got i think it's one of
some of the best food in any casino
i mean they put their [ __ ] bomb over
there they're doing it jack that's all
right [ __ ] breakfast dog i'm happy
with the three eggs in the [ __ ] bacon
can you imagine [ __ ] yeah that's how
simple i've become
here we go [ __ ] the church is
brought to you by one of my favorite
products let me explain something i did
business with these guys about three
years ago when we first started am i
bullshittingly
no they were one of our first they're
one of our first sponsors they sent us a
bunch of stuff
till today i still use their products
okay
so this is how much i like i always kept
their raises i always kept the main stem
i think they sent this like they sent me
like three main stems over the years
and i still have a [ __ ] backup okay
i don't know what i don't know how they
do it
but as far as razors and [ __ ]
the whole package they're the best in
the business and what makes them even
better is
they deliver it right to your house
you made the smarter choice
by switching to dollar shave club that's
a smart choice right now
dollar shave club will always be the
smarter choice
why because you get a great shave at a
great price
and it's conveniently delivered right to
your door it's an awesome
life hack no-brainer choice you no
longer have to step to the store to buy
a cheap disposable razor
that gave you a cheap shave or
spend the fortune on razors with
gimmicks and shaving tech you don't
really need
when i use the dss executive razor with
the doctor carver shea butter i use that
stuff in the shower
i pull up my sideburns i put it on my
face the doctor thing
i give it like a minute or two guys i
start shaving before i go in i make the
thing over here but my side burns
and i shave it off you actually see the
hair sticking to the [ __ ] shave cream
i can't give you the doctor carb is one
of the best products you could use you
understand me the dr carver's shave
butter is transparent for more precise
shave and helps prevent ingrown hairs
and it fights razor bumps you can make
the smarter choice by joining
dollar shave club and for a limited time
new members get their first month of the
executive razor with the tube you ready
for this of dr carver's shea butter for
only the finlaroo for five dollars with
free shipping you're not gonna beat that
nowhere after that raises are just a few
bucks a month that's a 15 value for five
bucks in your first month's box you're
gonna get an awesome weight handle which
i'm telling you i still got mine after
three years you're gonna get a full
cassette of four cartridges which will
last you these things are [ __ ]
tremendous they're sharp they get right
to the point and you can get a tube
of the shape butter after your first
month replacement carpet cartridges ship
automatically at their regular price
they're no hidden fees and no
commitments cancel
at any time you can only get this offer
from us at
dollarshaveclub.com church again
one month for five dollars that's
dollarshaveclub.com church again make
the smarter choice
five dollars
dollar shave club dot com slash church
number two
let me talk to you about something these
days you get everything on demand
it's like this podcast so why the hell
are you still going to the post office
dealing with limited hours standing
online like a mooc
when you can get postage on demand with
stamps.com
anything you can do at the post office
you could do right now
from your desk with stamps.com
buy and print official postage for any
letter or package using your own
computer and printer and unlike the post
office
stamps.com never closes listen you got a
little couple cocktails in here you're
in the mood to work you got a couple of
things to ship out
who needs sleep get the postage whenever
you need it 24 7. all right whenever my
wife uses stamp.com
she loves it you know why she puts it
out there and the mailman comes and
picks it up that's how good and
convenient this works you still got max
stamps.com
i do i still have the scale it works
great tremendous so what we're going to
do is this right now you're going to use
my name
joey for the special offer we're going
to give you a four week trial
this includes postage and we're going to
send you a digital scale
don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the home
page and type in joey listen you got a
small business you're trying to get a
small business started this is the
economical way to go you're a one-man
army you don't have time to hire
somebody to go to the post office it
takes too much time out of your day if
you're gonna do business this is the
smart way to do it right now it's the
only way stamps.com
right now enter joey stamps.com right
now enter joey never go to the post
office again your time is more valuable
than that i'll see you [ __ ]
thursday night
the bray improv but we'll see you
[ __ ] friday i got two shows and
saturday i got two shows either be there
or be square thursday night if you come
tell your boss you're not going to work
friday morning
tell them cosby's making the last
[ __ ] comeback
he's gonna fly in between court cases
and put gorilla biscuits in your [ __ ]
drinks
i want to thank uh stamps.com
again don't forget stamps.com
and to joey and i want to thank
dollarshaveclub.com
enter church and i always want to thank
honor.com they're our life
time sponsor everybody else is day one
listen i want to thank ralphie may as
usual always thank you to church i want
to thank my man lisa he didn't say
that but he was stoned is that b
is that b no
there's no b there's no there's a b
there's a b there's poor
kids no there's no b
you're not going to tell me that the
beat waited three hours to come out at
the end of the [ __ ] podcast
does it sting you
i mean
there's no [ __ ]
i've been trying to get him to forget
about that baby for the last like 20
minutes and what y'all didn't see is my
hand was over here just creeping and
trying to find us
and i swooped my finger down that was
the big
is
no july no august but then i'm back in
the fall okay they're giving me the
summer off because god bless them i'm
[ __ ] waiting for 2 000 degrees from
1000 degrees [ __ ] out like i'll blow
up
okay i couldn't take it uh but i'm at
harrah's of thursday friday saturday uh
come on uh
you guys are great i love you you're
coming out to vegas i'll make you laugh
hard i promise
okay i'm bona fide i love you have a
good night stay black see you wednesday
[ __ ]
hit that music baby
there you go wait
oh [ __ ]
you